[Musique]
je te peu dépassé par le journaliste et
écrivain et nous michel jean est encore
étonné par le succès de son roman qu
comme écoulé à près de 80 mille
exemplaires ce livre inspiré de
l'histoire de son arrière grand mère est
allé droit au coeur des lecteurs
les gersois encore à chaque jour - 10 15
20 messages de gens qui l'ont lu kinésie
je savais pas que ça s'est passé comme
ça je compte en avoir lu votre livre
monsieur jean c'est chaque jour encore
là en plus de michel jean les auteurs
naomi fontaine marie andrée guil natasha
khan était fontaine et joséphine bacon
faut briller la littérature autochtone
devant une telle abondance de talent les
éditions anorak lance la première
édition de l'événement en juin
je lis autochtone je pense que c'est une
illumination connu cette année moi de ma
conjointe que pour avec tout ce qui se
passe cette année on n'a pas tellement
parler des premières nations qu'on se
dit fallait profiter du mode juin pour
essayer de faire connaître encore plus
la littérature de premières nations
quake chine où une douzaine de
personnalités vont partager leurs
suggestions pour ce mois de la
littérature autochtone pour la poète
innu du lac saint jean marie-andrée gül
l'événement est symbolique pendant
tellement longtemps notre histoire était
un culte y pleut maintenant ben on les
gens sont prêts et les gens des
premières nations au 613 excess ça se
rencontrent ce mois de la littérature
autochtone est aussi portée par un vent
de changement dans les librairies
ici les auteurs des premières nations
occupe une place de choix une grande
demande pour ça vraiment d
si je peux dès maintenant et des baisses
salaire de littérature autochtone qui
est vraiment une très bonne nouvelle
sur une belle lancée michel jean
attribue son succès en partie au
contexte actuel de france québec sainte
et comme un révélateur mais entre les
deux d'arrivée la fête joyce et chaque
fois je passe au vert les coeurs et les
esprits de beaucoup de québécois jeu
soudainement son 10e rang qui êtes en
retard un peu sur sa sept rencontres
entre écrivains autochtones et de
nouveaux lecteurs nous démontre une page
à la fois que la littérature est un
vecteur de dialogue et d'empathie ici
louis philippe ouimet radio canada
montréal
[Musique]